Ok, donc là c'est juste en vue de l'ensemble, c'est qu'on va croiser dans la première étape.
Serviteur d'office, notre idée des diacres à la biblique,
donc c'est la structure plus ou moins similaire à celle du livre,
avec quelques autres vers la fin, on peut ajouter.
Et donc, ces passages, on sait très bien,
il s'agit plutôt des précurseurs des diacres, qui est l'office du diacre.
Ce n'est pas encore un situé.
Et dans un premier moment, ces titres, serviteurs d'office,
c'est pour qu'on se rappelle qu'il nous semble devant quelque chose d'officiel,
que le Seigneur Jésus-Christ a voulu instituer pour l'Église.
Mais de manière très intéressante, comme on voit pour, par exemple, la création de la femme,
c'est intéressant de remarquer que Dieu avait d'abord créé l'homme,
et même si Dieu avait déjà l'intention, il avait déjà planifié,
qu'il avait déjà établi dans son cœur l'importance de la femme et qu'il allait la créer,
et donc la rendre à l'homme.
C'est important de nous rappeler que Dieu permet quand même qu'Adam arrive à ces mêmes constats,
qu'il perçoit les besoins, la nécessité,
qu'il soit déjà en contact avec la création,
et qu'il perçoive qu'il n'était pas complet,
qu'il avait besoin de la femme.
Et donc Dieu ensuite va créer la femme.
Quelque part, c'est ça qu'on voit dans ces passages,
on voit l'Église qui commence à grandir,
et la question qu'on se pose, c'est d'où viennent les diacres ?
Est-ce que les diacres, c'est une institution humaine ?
Et ça, c'est une question très légitime à se poser,
car on sait qu'aujourd'hui, il y a plusieurs Églises
qui ont développé plusieurs autres offices,
qui vont ordonner des personnes pour exercer certains offices
qu'on ne trouve pas dans les Écritures.
Mais quand on s'approche des Écritures,
on voit qu'il y a un nombre très limité d'offices,
et surtout pour la continuité de l'Église,
on n'a qu'il y a deux offices.
On n'a plus des apôtres,
on n'a plus des évangélistes avec un E majuscule,
ni des prophètes avec un P majuscule.
Mais nous avons cette notion d'anciens et diacres,
qui sont les officiers de l'Église.
Et donc, c'est très important de nous rappeler,
quand on pense à un office,
ça nous ramène, ça nous renvoie à la notion de l'Église
en tant qu'ambassade officielle des dieux sur terre.
Ça devrait produire en nous une sensation de crainte,
de révérence, de respect,
car les diacres ne sont pas les produits,
ils ne sont pas l'idée en tant qu'office,
ils ne sont pas l'idée des êtres humains.
Ce ne sont pas les Églises qui, à un moment donné,
se sont dit, on va créer maintenant les ouvriers,
on va créer maintenant la conception moderne des missionnaires.
Donc là, on est devant un office biblique
et on appelle serviteur d'office.
Pourquoi ? Pour nous rappeler que pour plus qu'ils soient
et qu'ils deviennent officiellement les serviteurs de l'Église,
ils ne sont pas les seuls serviteurs de l'Église.
Tous les ministères, la parole ou les mots ministères
veut dire aussi service,
tout comme les mots diacres veut dire aussi service et ministère.
Et donc, il y a des distinctions dans la Bible,
selon le contexte,
où les mots pour les services diacres
vont s'appliquer officiellement à un office de l'Église,
mais dans la majorité des fois
où cette parole dans l'original va apparaître,
elle va tout simplement signifier service.
Et donc, dans un certain sens,
même l'essai en Jésus-Christ est appelé un diacre.
Dans un certain sens,
tous les chrétiens doivent se voir comme serviteurs,
nous avons tous des ministères.
Par contre, il y a cette distinction évidente dans la Bible.
Ici, c'est intéressant de remarquer
que les diacres, ils sont avant tout l'idée des dieux.
Donc, Dieu, dans son institution divine,
dans son désir d'organiser l'Église,
il avait planifié que l'Église
aurait sa continuité avec deux offices,
les anciens, pasteurs,
et les diacres.
Par contre, c'est intéressant de remarquer
comment la Providence va démontrer à l'Église
l'importance de l'établissement
de ses rôles au sein de l'Église
et que ce soit un rôle officiel,
que ce soit quelque chose qui fasse partie
de la structure de l'Église.
L'Église est un organisme vivant,
mais qui a besoin des structures.
Ces structures se montrent dans la Bible
par les offices qu'elles nous présentent.
On a besoin des diacres,
on a besoin des anciens.
Et une Église qui n'a pas des anciens, des diacres,
elle n'est pas complète en termes officiels.
Elle n'est pas une Église ordonnée
selon l'institution divine.
Donc, quand on pense à la relation
entre structure et organicité,
on ne doit pas penser à la structure d'entrepreneur.
Et ça, c'est un risque que nous avons très constamment.
Il y a beaucoup de formations des diacres
ou des formations des pasteurs
qui pensent qu'ils savent allaitrement
de former les diacres ou les pasteurs
et qui vont prêter du milieu entrepreneur
plein de principes d'hierarchie, d'organisation.
Sauf que quand on va vers la Bible,
comme disait Lloyd-Jones,
les appelés, les vocations,
les offices publics,
ils ne sont pas formés par les hommes.
Ils sont plutôt reconnus comme un don des dieux.
C'est Dieu qui les crée.
Lloyd-Jones disait, les pasteurs,
il n'est pas fait, il est né.
À un moment donné,
lorsque Dieu nous appelle envers un ministère,
il engendre en nous les mêmes qualifications
et les dons dont on a besoin pour les exercer.
Et donc, bien sûr qu'au fur et à mesure,
attention à ce que je vais vous dire,
on va prendre conscience
de la structure que Dieu nous a donnée.
et nous chercherons à agir en conformité
avec cette structure.
Par exemple,
lorsqu'il y a...
Comment on appelle les papillons
avant qu'ils soient papillons ?
Chénies.
Parce que la chénie va devenir un papillon,
elle n'est pas très responsable
pour cette transformation
qui sera opérée en elle-même.
Mais elle aura une toute nouvelle structure.
Et donc, les chrétiens,
les appelés, les vocations,
c'est plutôt une question
de prendre conscience de cette transformation
en contemplant quelques évidences
qui pointent déjà
dans la direction de notre vocation.
Donc, il y a des évidences concrètes,
claires, évidentes,
d'appel, des transformations.
Mais le plus on essaie de comprendre
dans la Bible
quelle est cette structure,
le plus on constate
que c'est une réalité
à propos de nous-mêmes
et que nous avons reçu
des forces, des potentiels
pour les exercer.
Et donc, on doit avoir au moins
une conviction embryonnaire
de notre appel.
Et à la mesure où on s'efforce
pour remplir cet appel,
on constate que le Saint-Esprit
est en train de pouvoir les forces.
Et donc, c'est important pour nous
de nous rappeler,
étant une institution divine,
étant un office divan,
faisant partie
de l'aspect officiel de l'Église,
c'est important de nous rappeler
que c'est Dieu lui-même
qui donne à l'Église.
Il fait ses dons à l'Église
en fournissant à l'Église
les ministères.
Donc, ils sont plutôt reconnus
qui est produit par l'Église.
Ils doivent être accueillis,
chéris et encouragés
au sein de l'Église.
Et ils doivent avoir
un niveau conscient
de leur vocation particulière.
Donc, d'où vient le diacre ?
De la Providence.
L'Église grandissait
et elle a perçu en besoin
que les pasteurs
ne soient pas chargés
avec des occupations
qui n'étaient pas liées
à leur priorité primaire.
ce n'est pas comme si
les apôtres
ou les anciens
n'étaient pas disposés
à servir aux tables.
Mais ils ont compris
que s'ils sont très occupés
en servissant aux tables,
ils ne peuvent pas
remplir leurs fonctions
comme il faut.
Ils doivent consacrer
leur plan temps
pour leur vocation,
pour les ministères de la prière
et les ministères de la parole.
et donc des personnes
qui savent chérir
la vocation particulière
des anciens,
qui veulent tellement promouvoir
les ministères de la parole
et de la prière,
qui veulent bien sûr
travailler pour l'olité de l'Église.
Donc, ils voient les besoins
de servir comme des catalyseurs,
comme ceux qui vont maximiser
la possibilité des anciens
pour travailler
pour l'avancement du royaume
dans leur fonction
qui est prééminente,
la fonction des anciens.
Et donc,
c'est une institution divine.
C'est une institution divine
qui montre sa nécessité
et son efficacité
par la providence
et nous devons donc
avoir un égard
distinct
entre la notion
des services généraux
de laquelle les diacques
sont un modèle
et un rôle officiel
de l'Église,
la maison des dieux.
Donc, voici quelques principes
importants à remarquer
pour cette distinction
d'office.
Donc là, nous sommes tous diacres.
Christ est appelé diacre,
tous les chrétiens sont diacres,
mais il y a les diacres d'office.
L'Église est un organisme organisé,
il y a de la vie,
mais il y a aussi une structure.
L'Église,
ce qui devrait ressortir
quand on contemple
ou on pense à l'Église
n'est pas forcément
la visibilité de son structure,
comme dans les églises épiscopales,
anglicaines, etc.
Mais c'est la vie de l'Église.
En même temps,
lorsqu'on voit
un organisme sans structure,
donc ces mouvements
de la société des prophètes
sans Église,
les déçus avec l'Église,
là, il n'y a pas de forme,
c'est tellement dilué,
il n'y a pas de substance,
il n'y a pas des vies concrètes
qu'on voit avec l'arté.
Et donc, il faut qu'on ait
une structure.
Donc, l'Église est un organisme
qui va s'organiser
et va rendre officielle
cette organisation
à un moment donné
quand on lit les Écritures.
C'est intéressant,
l'un des critères
les plus évidents
dans ces passages
lorsqu'ils ont choisi ces hommes,
c'était des hommes
remplis de Saint-Esprit.
Donc, il faut qu'on se rappelle
bien
que pour plus
que les travails
directs des diacres
soient des travails
très tangibles,
très concrets,
ils ne sont pas
en train de s'occuper
frontalement
de la prédication de la parole
ou du ministère de la prière,
par contre,
ils sont là pour ça.
Ils sont là notamment
pour promouvoir
la prière et la parole.
C'est-à-dire,
les Saint-Esprits
ont tellement travaillé
dans leur vie
qu'ils ont contemplé
comme évidence
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit,
non seulement
les fruits de l'Esprit
en caractère moral,
chose que nous devrions
trouver dans tous
les chrétiens,
mais c'est un remplissage
du Saint-Esprit
qui leur a donné
une appréciation particulière,
un amour
pour les ministères
de la parole,
une conscience
du besoin
du ministère de la parole,
du ministère de la prière
et tellement
ils chérissent
le ministère de la parole
et de la prière,
ils vont contempler
des évidences
qu'ils veulent
promouvoir
ces ministères.
Donc,
ils seront
particulièrement présents
dans les principales réunions
de l'Église
où la parole est prêchée,
où l'Église
est rassemblée
pour prier.
Et c'est là
où ils seront constamment
en train de faciliter
et maximiser
ces ministères.
Donc,
ils sont là,
conscients
qu'ils doivent libérer
les anciens
pour ces ministères,
mais aussi,
c'est une évidence
de l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit.
Car c'est quoi
l'évidence maximale
de l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit ?
Donc,
Jean-Éttoile,
quand il a écrit son livre
à propos
de l'œuvre de l'Esprit,
pour nous aider
à évaluer
un vrai réveil,
il a dit
la manière
dont on réagit
à la présence
du Saint-Esprit
en termes spectaculaires,
en termes émotifs,
n'est pas forcément
l'évidence majeure
de l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit.
C'est plutôt
certains éléments
qui caractérisent
les personnes
qui ont été
véritablement l'objet
de l'enfance
du Saint-Esprit,
c'est-à-dire
un amour plus grand
pour Christ,
pour l'Évangile,
pour les perdus,
une appréciation
et un amour
pour la parole de Dieu,
pour la prière
et un amour
pour l'Église.
Et donc,
si,
pour occuper cette tâche,
cette personne
doit être remplie
du Saint-Esprit,
comment pouvons-nous observer
la réalité ?
Dans ce cas-là,
c'est clair,
c'est des personnes
qui voulaient maximiser
la parole,
la prière
car ils appréciaient
et donc,
c'est une tâche spirituelle.
Voilà pourquoi
c'est important
d'être rempli
du Saint-Esprit
et c'est une tâche
spirituelle
même si
l'occupation directe
semble être
servir au table,
promouvoir l'unité
de l'Église,
faire des choses
très pratiques
pour libérer les anciens.
Et donc,
là,
on voit de manière
très claire,
il s'agit
de la chose
la plus spirituelle,
de s'occuper
de ces questions aussi.
Ils sont les serviteurs
d'office.
Et donc là,
c'est cette notion
de l'Église
en tant qu'ambassade
et la conviction
qu'on a été commissionné
pour occuper
une position officielle.
C'est qui porte
ou devrait porter
un énorme privilège,
mais qui devrait porter
aussi une crante
assez sévère
et solennelle.
Donc là,
c'est de répondre
directement à l'évaluation
divine,
à la supervision
des dieux
qui est toujours
très bien présent
avec son zèle
envers son Église.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant aussi
de remarquer
dans ces passages
qu'il n'a plus
à l'assemblée
d'avoir établi
cette classe
des serviteurs
et il y a aussi
la manifestation
d'un résultat.
La parole de Dieu
se répandait
de plus en plus.
Le nombre
des disciples
augmentait
beaucoup à Jérusalem
et une grande foule
de sacrificateurs
obéissaient à la foi.
Il y a une particularité
assez intéressante ici
quand ils évoquent
les sacrificateurs
car les sacrificateurs
de l'Ancien Testament,
ils avaient un rôle
profondément diaconal.
Ils avaient un rôle
plus que ça,
mais c'est incroyable
quand on lit
les Lévitiques,
Nombre,
les Pentateuch
de manière générale
et de contempler
la quantité
des tâches,
d'occupations
tout simplement
pour la préparation
des besoins tangibles,
d'organisation
au sein du Temple,
du tabernacle,
notamment afin
que les ministères
puissent avoir lieu.
Et donc,
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
l'institution
de ces hommes
et cette connexion,
cette mention
des sacrificateurs
qui étaient convertis
aussi.
Donc,
il y a la croissance
d'Église
qui est une raison
pour plus d'organisation
et il y a
les résultats
qui ont aussi
encore plus
la croissance d'Église
une fois que l'Église
est plus organisée.
Donc,
on a
et on prie,
on a un désir profond
pour que notre Église
croite en termes
d'anciens.
On a beaucoup
d'anciens formations
proportionnellement
à la taille
de notre Église
et on a aussi
beaucoup de conversations
avec l'équipe pastorale
pour qu'ils puissent
se consacrer davantage
au ministère.
En même temps,
il y a beaucoup
de choses
qui sont déjà
en route
et en place
au sein de notre Église
qu'on aimerait
qui soient mieux faites,
qu'on ait plus
d'excellence
dans la manière
de faire certaines choses
au sein de l'Église.
Donc,
il y a beaucoup
de services
qui sont faits
de manière très excellente
mais il y a beaucoup
de services
qui pourraient être faits
afin de maximiser
davantage
les ministères
de la parole
et de la prière.
Et donc,
c'est important
de considérer
de quelle manière
notre Église grandirait.
Par exemple,
il y a beaucoup
de travail qui est fait
par exemple
pour qu'on trouve
un bâtiment.
Donc,
c'est un travail
qui est fait
avec excellence,
avec effort.
Mais juste pour évoquer
les besoins
d'un bâtiment
comme quelque chose
qui pourrait maximiser
davantage
la croissance
de notre Église.
Et donc,
avec ça,
il y aura une entendance,
une maintenance
de bâtiment.
Donc,
il y a des choses
qui vont croître
avec ça.
Et il y a beaucoup
d'organisations aussi
qu'on doit avoir
pour l'interaction
entre les ministères
de notre Église
en termes
de communication.
On pourrait
ouvrir
des nouveaux fronts,
en fait,
fournir des ressources,
même des enseignements,
des prédications.
Il y a beaucoup
de choses
qui pourraient être maximisées
avec l'aide
des diacres.
Et donc,
ce sont des choses
qu'on va discuter
plus tard.
Mais pour l'instant,
c'est juste pour démontrer
que la croissance
de l'Église
démontre les besoins
et elle va aussi
promouvoir.
Voilà.
Est-ce que vous avez
des questions jusqu'ici ?
Et donc,
la prochaine question
qu'on pose,
c'est,
si le point numéro un,
c'est un office,
ok,
c'est un serviteur
par office,
un serviteur officiel,
la deuxième question,
c'est,
même si nous savons
reconnaître
que les diacres
sont officiels
au sein de l'Église,
est-ce que notre idée
des diacres
est-elle biblique ?
Ok ?
Donc ici,
c'est les passages
qui vont décrire
de manière très claire
ce qui devrait être
un diacre,
comment nous devrions
identifier les diacres
et quelles sont
ses fonctions
au sein de l'Église.
Et le problème,
c'est qu'aujourd'hui,
on a plein d'Églises
qui ont
les diacres
qui fonctionnent
avec les titres officiels,
mais qui ne fonctionnent pas
en harmonie
avec ce que la parole
de Dieu nous présente
et,
en même temps,
qui n'ont pas
les qualifications
pour être reconnus
et ordonnés
comme diacres.
Et donc,
la grande question
pour nous,
c'est,
sur ces points-là,
est-ce que notre idée
des diacres,
elle est biblique ?
Donc,
l'auteur du livre,
il va nous présenter
au départ,
en survol.
Voilà.
Donc là,
d'abord,
il nous apporte
cette notion
que la présence
ou l'absence
des diacres
sera là
pour les biens
ou pour les pires
de l'Église.
Donc,
nous,
on a récemment été,
on a fait beaucoup
d'efforts
pour aider une Église
où il y avait
beaucoup de confusion
entre les rôles
de l'ancien
et les rôles des diacres.
Et,
cette Église
a vécu
des décisions
à un moment donné,
des pasteurs
qui sont partis
et il y avait
qu'il y a des diacres
qui sont restés.
Donc,
ils ont fait
ce travail héroïque
de chercher
à nourrir l'Église,
même si ce n'était
pas leur vocation,
pendant l'absence
d'un pasteur.
En même temps,
ils ont développé
une espèce
d'instinct
de protection
de l'Église
et qui est fini
pour devenir
une espèce
des sensations
des propriétés
de cette Église.
Et même si plus tard,
ils ont reçu
autre pasteur,
ces pasteurs
n'ont pas trouvé
de l'espace
pour travailler
car il y avait
beaucoup de résistance
par rapport
au rôle des diacres.
Et cette histoire
se passe
de manière
très répétitive.
Des personnes
qui vont agir
comme les propriétaires
de l'Église
car ils sont là
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps.
Il y a plein d'Églises
qui disent
qu'ils ont besoin
des pasteurs
mais lorsque les pasteurs
n'arrivent pas
à travailler,
leur enseignement
n'est pas reçu
car il y a
beaucoup de résistance
de la part
des diacres.
Il y a beaucoup
de mauvaises conceptions
et donc les diacres
seront là
au sein de l'Église
pour les biens
ou pour les pires.
Si les diacres
sont véritablement
bibliques,
dans leur qualification
et dans leur manière
d'agir,
l'Église va prospérer.
Mais si les diacres
sont là
sans la conception
publique,
ça va rendre
cette Église
très malade
et empêcher
sa prospérité.
Et donc
dans un survol historique,
on voit comment
l'Église primitive
avait ses axes
de compréhension
de l'occupation
des diacres
qui est très biblique.
Donc travailler
et protéger
pour l'unité
de l'Église,
faire des œuvres
des miséricordes
et supporter
les ministères pastorales,
appuyer les ministères
pastorales.
Ensuite,
plus tard,
avec la formalisation
ou la croissance
en formalisation
de l'ordre ecclésial.
Donc on peut penser
à la conversion
des Constantin
qui a importé
beaucoup
de la structure
de l'Empire romain
au sein de l'Église.
Et donc
tout office biblique
qui devrait être
plutôt caractérisé
par l'humilité,
ok,
une ferme leadership
mais avec beaucoup
d'amour d'humilité,
donc c'est plutôt
la pyramide
à l'inverse
que Jésus nous a proposée,
mais la réalité
c'est qu'on a reproduit
la pyramide
de l'Empire romain.
Donc on va
commencer à voir
comment dans
l'ordre ecclésial
déjà
les diacres
deviennent
un tremplant
ou un pas
dans l'échelle
pour devenir anciens,
ce qui n'est pas
de tout public,
public, pardon.
Ils étaient
les officiers
des œuvres
des charités,
pardon,
ils étaient les officiers
donc il y a eu
une tendance
à la cléricalisation,
donc on va penser
à tous les endumentaires,
les vêtements,
tous ces couvrages
mystiques
et donc
une formalisation
presque idolâtre
et exagérée
et
pardon,
formelle,
administrative
et hiérarchique.
Et donc voilà,
c'était,
pardon,
j'ai sauté au Moyen-Âge
mais c'était juste
une formalisation,
ils occupaient plus
des rôles administratifs
et ça sonnait plus
à la notion
d'hiérarchie.
Et donc ça va
s'approfondir
pendant le Moyen-Âge,
donc c'est à partir de là
jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive
au XVIe siècle
que nous voyons
les plus grandes transformations
des hérésies catholiques,
des corruptions catholiques
et à ce point-là,
ils deviennent
donc bien sûr
voilà,
une étape
pour devenir
du haut clergé,
ils deviennent donc
partis du clergé
et il y a cette notion
des pertes
de services
et des travaux
beaucoup plus administratifs
pour l'Église catholique.
Donc c'est là
où on voit
le sommet de la corruption
du rôle de diacre
quand on est
au Moyen-Âge.
Et donc c'était
un accent mis
sur la cérémonie
et sur les pouvoirs
et donc ils étaient là
pour devenir prêtres.
Donc voilà pourquoi
en revenant
à cette image
nous voyons
la représentation
des plusieurs étapes
les lecteurs,
l'exorciste,
l'acolyte,
je n'arrive pas à lire,
voilà,
subdiacre,
diacre
et les prêtres.
Donc ça,
c'était même
la structure
des Églises anglicaines
qui n'ont pas fait
un travail substantiel
aussi pour restaurer
la notion biblique
après la réforme
qu'ils ont traversée.
Donc là,
on voit même
par exemple
dans les Églises
les plus épiscopales
de nos jours
dans leur gouvernance
comme par exemple
les Églises pentecôtistes,
on peut imaginer
l'ouvrier,
l'évangéliste,
les responsables
du ministère
des consécrations,
etc.
Car pour eux aussi
ce sont des étapes,
les lévites encore
et tout ça.
Donc là,
on ne voit pas
une conception claire
des offices particuliers,
des vocations particulières,
mais une notion
d'échelle.
donc,
avec la réforme
et particulièrement
à travers Calvin,
il y a une restauration
très substantielle
de ces ministères
qui revient à la base
biblique de la charité
et un modèle
des services bibliques.
Et donc,
on revient à cette notion
de l'appui
au ministère de la parole
où les diacres
ne sont plus vus
comme un office
à temps plein
rémunérés,
mais on revient.
Donc,
des fois,
il y a un besoin
pour que certaines églises
aient quelques diacres
à temps plein.
Donc,
il y avait cette réalité,
mais l'emphase
mise par Calvin,
c'était différent
de l'église catholique
revenant à cette notion
plus biblique.
Et ensuite,
on a dans la modernité,
donc c'est après la réforme
avec les formations
des dénominations historiques,
donc les presbytériens,
les baptistes,
les anglicans,
etc.
C'est à partir de là
qu'on va commencer
à voir,
par exemple,
une fragmentation
dénominationale,
c'est-à-dire,
selon l'église,
un accent particulier
sera mis
et un aspect
du ministère
dédié à accédera
sera plus mis en emphase
et on va perdre,
en fait,
cette notion
de tous les rôles
qu'il devrait accomplir.
Donc,
juste pour vous donner
quelques exemples,
quand on pense
aux presbytériens,
les diacres,
vont fonctionner
un peu plus
comme l'aide
d'administration,
l'aide pour les finances
et surtout
des œuvres
des miséricordes.
OK ?
Donc,
administration des finances
et œuvres des miséricordes.
Pour les anglicans,
il y a cette transition
envers la prétérie
qui est gardée,
donc,
comme on a vu,
là,
l'échelle.
Donc,
il y a cette notion
comme s'il était
une étape
pour développer
les ministères
jusqu'à ce qu'on
devienne les prêtres.
Donc,
là,
les anglicans,
voilà,
ce que l'auteur
va dire,
c'est que si on coupe
un évêque,
on va trouver
un ancien,
si on coupe un ancien,
on va trouver des dents
en diacre,
en archédiacre,
ensuite un diacre,
etc.
Et donc,
c'est comme si
les services des diacres
étaient la première étape
pour devenir ministre.
Et donc,
bien sûr que certains
qui sont appelés au ministère
ont pu commencer
à travailler en tant que diacre,
mais ce n'est pas la règle,
ce n'est pas la norme biblique.
Et ensuite,
les congrégationnels
et les baptistes,
donc c'est intéressant
car les baptistes,
ils se sont corrompus
très tard à cet égard,
mais plus récemment,
il y a eu cette transition
envers la notion
d'un seul ancien,
car dans l'origine
réformée baptiste,
on était toujours
la pluralité d'anciens
et les diacres
avec un bon fonctionnement.
Mais là,
les diacres,
ils passent à fonctionner
dans la plupart
des églises baptistes
comme les conseils
de l'église,
comme pour les presbytériens,
ils font la distinction
entre les pasteurs
et les anciens.
Et dans les cadres baptistes,
c'est un seul pasteur
dans la plupart des églises
et ensuite,
on a un conseil
des diacres.
Et là,
c'est...
Voilà,
on verra
quels sont les dangers
de ces choses,
mais ce n'est pas biblique
cette notion
car le rôle des diacres
n'est pas d'être
un conseil
directif,
consultif
de l'église,
mais c'est d'être
un appui
à la direction
que Dieu a donnée
à la pluralité
des anciens.
Donc,
dans l'actualité,
on a
une confusion
et une redécouverte.
Donc,
il y a pas mal
de confusion
quand on pense
au diacre
aujourd'hui
et c'est pour ça
qu'il va évoquer
quelques personnages
fictifs,
mais il y a aussi
un espoir
pour la redécouverte.
Donc,
quand on pense
à la confusion,
j'ai un peu changé
les noms là
pour être encore plus drôle,
mais...
C'est là où je dois changer.
Voilà.
Et donc,
je pense qu'il y en a
tous croisé
des églises
qui ont
ce type
de perspectives
envers l'ancien.
Donc,
on voit un homme très...
Voilà.
La mauvaise conception
de l'ancien formation.
on va...
Et donc,
bien sûr que
tous les anciens
en formation
doivent aussi
passer par une période
probatoire
pour qu'on puisse
évaluer sa fidélité.
Et donc,
moi,
je me rappelle
très bien
mes occupations
très fatigantes
à l'église.
Je devais
enregistrer
les prédications.
Et à l'époque,
c'était encore
les CD.
Donc,
j'ai des vrais...
Et là,
c'était une église
de 600 membres.
Et il y avait
des commandes
de 200 CD
par semaine.
Et j'ai des vrais
en par an
coller des étiquettes,
enregistrer,
éditer,
etc.
Et donc,
c'était un travail
tellement nécessaire.
Mais c'était
un travail
qui portait
beaucoup de défis
et qui ne donnait
pas de retour
financier.
C'était vraiment
une des manières
que mon église
a trouvées
pour travailler
ces périodes
probatoires
pour voir
la prédisposition
à servir
et la constance
dans les services.
Sans oscillation,
constance,
persévérance.
Et donc là,
je trouve intéressant.
Par contre,
cet aspect
de l'évaluation
pastorale
ne peut pas
être confondu
avec les ministères
des diacres.
Car les diacres,
c'est l'appel particulier
qu'ils ont.
C'est d'être
toujours là
pour servir.
Et donc là,
c'est une mauvaise
conception car
on risque
de pousser
les personnes
à servir
dans une ère
où ils n'ont pas été appelés,
ils n'ont pas été doués
pour les faire.
Et ça,
c'est très dangereux
sans l'église.
Ensuite,
on parle des brises bricots,
un réparateur,
les bricoleurs.
Et donc,
c'est une tentation
pour les églises.
On a souvent
beaucoup de problèmes
avec la maintenance
du bâtiment,
l'électricité,
plein de choses
qui ont lieu.
et si une personne
est qualifiée
appelée pour être ancienne,
c'est super
qu'ils soient qualifiés
et qu'ils puissent
servir dans cette ère.
Mais des personnes
peuvent nous aider
à régler certaines choses
sans recevoir l'office
s'ils n'ont pas l'appel.
C'est clair ?
Et donc là,
c'est un problème aussi
lorsque,
juste car les personnes
sont douées
pour faire un service,
on les met
dans l'office des diacres
mais on n'a pas
bien évalué
l'évidence d'être rempli
de Saint-Esprit,
les qualifications morales,
etc.
Donc il ne peut pas
être un modèle officiel
pour l'Église
des serviteurs
s'il n'est pas
rempli de Saint-Esprit,
il n'a pas
cette conviction.
Donc Arnaud Argent,
ça c'est une tentation
surtout dans la génération
avec ce qu'on appelait
la mech d'organisation
de l'Église,
c'est-à-dire
des Églises
qui sont parties
vers les méthodes
de croissance
avec des principes
d'entrepreneurs.
Et donc ce sont
des Églises
qui veulent grandir vite
et vont toujours
choisir pour travailler
proche du pasteur
des personnes
qui sont très réussies
dans la société.
Et donc si c'est
quelqu'un
qui est un grand gesteur,
etc.
Et les problèmes,
gestionnaires,
les problèmes
c'est que
pour plus
que l'assistance
diaconale
soit là aussi
pour aider
avec quelques fonctions
administratives
de gestion,
la réalité
c'est que
la direction
et les critères
pour avancer
les rangs des jeux
ne sont pas les mêmes
qui sont ceux
des entreprises.
Donc des fois
l'Église va devoir
prendre des risques
financiers même,
des risques
et une personne
qui est très entraînée
avec la mentalité
entrepreneur
ne va pas vouloir
oser aller
dans une telle direction.
Et lorsque Dieu
met dans la conviction
des pasteurs
qu'il faut aller
dans une direction,
c'est le travail
des diacres
de nous donner
une assistance
pour qu'on sache
mesurer
les ressources matérielles
et nous dire
peut-être qu'on n'a pas
encore les ressources
pour les faire
sauf que si les pasteurs
sont convaincus
merci de votre aide
on est conscient
mais on est convaincu
qu'il faut quand même
y aller.
Donc c'est eux
qui vont rendre compte
des vendus
par rapport à ces choses.
Par contre
l'information
et la sensibilité
des diacres
elle est importante.
Le problème
c'est que quand
ils commencent à fonctionner
en tant qu'anciens
les gesteurs
ils ont une tendance
à très limiter
les potentiels
spirituels
de l'Église
à plusieurs égards.
Dans la pratique
c'est comme ça
que ça se passe
et donc c'est important
d'avoir des diacres
doués
dans cette ère-là
mais c'est important
qu'ils ne fonctionnent pas
comme
et les plus sensibles
ceux qui sont vraiment appelés
ils sauront
qu'il y a leur tâche
d'informer
et d'assister
elle saura
assimiler les défis
mais il saura aussi
vouloir avancer
en tant qu'Église.
Il saura appuyer
la vision
que les anciens
ont reçue à cet égard
et donc
Arnaud Argent
l'homme d'affaires
donc ensuite
il a Victor Lévéto
donc c'est l'homme
qui peut dire non
donc ça c'est
c'est assez intéressant
donc c'est
voilà
ça c'est les types
des diacres
que j'ai cités
dans l'expérience
de cette église
tout ce que les pasteurs
voulaient faire
il y avait toujours
une résistance
et donc ils sont là
pour maximiser
pour faciliter
et pas pour occuper
une position
où ils ont plutôt
l'impression
qu'ils sont un peu
les propriétaires
de l'église
et donc ça
normalement ça a lieu
quand on fait
une distinction
très rigide
entre la relation
entre la dimension
des services
des anciens
et la dimension
du service
des diacres
si on va limiter
totalement
la dimension
du service
des diacres
aux questions
tangibles
concrètes
et on va limiter
la question
des anciens
à la gestion
des questions
spirituelles
on va perdre
de vue
l'effet
que la direction
des anciens
se porte
envers les concrètes
et on va perdre
de vue
que les diacres
ils n'ont pas
tous les droits
pour décider
toutes les choses
par rapport
à tout ce qui est concret
donc là par exemple
ce type d'église
c'est les bâtiments
la couleur des murs
il y a plein de choses
qui pensent
que les pasteurs
ne peuvent pas
dire aucune chose
c'est au diacre
de résoudre
car ce sont
des maisons concrets
et c'est pas du tout
comme ça
que l'église fonctionne
donc cette vision
les principes bibliques
pour toute direction
pour l'église
viennent
par la direction
des anciens
formés par la Bible
et les diacres
sont là
pour faciliter
la vision
que Dieu
a donnée
à ses anciens
et bien sûr
qui parfois
ils peuvent proposer
suggérer
c'est comme dans une relation
maritale
dans un certain sens
où l'homme ne va pas
négliger l'assistance
de son épouse
mais parfois
il sentira quand même
que la direction
que Dieu
est en train de donner
à la famille
les décisions vont
reposer sur lui
il va prendre en considération
mais si jamais
il faut marcher
dans une telle direction
ils vont devoir
conduire de cette manière
et l'épouse
va devoir savoir
accueillir
en ayant
considéré
que sa contribution
a été considérée
a été accueillie
et elle va
vouloir quand même
faciliter la direction
et il y a
qu'en temps
quasi ancien
on les diacres patrons
donc c'est juste
cet homme là
qui pense
que sa position
officielle
en tant que serviteur
lui permet
de protéger
l'église
même des anciens
et comme ça
ça commence
à mêler
les relations
bien sûr
pour que tout ça
marche bien
il faut que les anciens
soient qualifiés aussi
soient des vrais anciens appelés
car des fois
il y a un homme
rempli de son esprit
en diacres
qui voit
et qui voit
et qui a
les sentiments
les désirs
de protéger l'église
des mauvais pasteurs
est-ce que vous avez
des questions
oui
si on a des philippes
et d'étienne
oui
mais c'est pas
la responsabilité des diacs
c'est la responsabilité
de toute la congrégation
on peut trouver
dans la congrégation
des personnes
encore plus sensibles
et encore plus capables
d'évaluer les principes publics
par rapport
à ce qui est un ancien
donc c'est pas
au diacre
de décider
de nominer
voilà
mais
bien sûr
qu'il devrait avoir
une participation
plus substantielle
au sein de cette église
donc ça dépend vraiment
de l'état de santé des diacres
par contre
une question
qui est importante
c'est
ça peut
ça peut devenir
une manifestation
des manques
des fois
et des confiances
dans les promesses
de Dieu
pardon
quand on pense
que Dieu
ne va pas pouvoir
un pasteur
dans la plupart des cas
c'est plutôt
l'église
les membres
ou les diacres
qui sont en train
d'empêcher
l'oeuvre de Dieu
sans l'église
car l'église
il a promis
qu'il allait pouvoir
des ministres
à l'évangile
donc c'est plutôt
nous
soit individuellement
qui résistons
à son appel
soit
l'église
elle-même
donc par exemple
si elle pense
avec des critères financiers
on n'a pas
l'argent
pour avoir un pasteur
aujourd'hui
ça c'est pas
un motif
pour ne pas avoir
un pasteur
on va tous
s'immobiliser
s'est sacrifié
on va tous
faire ce qu'il faut
pour pouvoir
avoir cette personne
au sein de notre église
et donc la question
financière
n'est pas les critères
les signes
les évidences
d'appel
devraient toujours
être observés
chéris
et l'église
devrait réagir vite
on ne sait pas
si Dieu
veut provoquer
une persécution
à l'église
pour qu'on soit éparpillé
tant mieux
si un jour
cela arrive
et qu'il y en a
plusieurs personnes
qui ont été reconnues
comme appelées
formées
et maintenant
on fera
l'effet
là où on sera
donc une église
elle ne doit pas
réagir aux diacres
et aux anciens
tout simplement
à la mesure
où les besoins
apparaissent
elle doit être
toujours attentive
pour identifier
des personnes
au sein de la communauté
qui ont la conviction
de l'appel
et qui démontrent
l'évidence de l'appel
et donc
déjà
des églises
sans pasteur
et sans diacre
peuvent être
des évidences
de mauvaise santé
et donc
sinon
on serait
en train
de mettre
en question
la promesse
du Christ
qui a promis
qu'il allait
donner
toujours
aux églises
des diacres
et des pasteurs
donc c'est plutôt
nous qui résistons
à l'appel
et c'est l'église
qui va réfléchir
avec des critères
qui ne sont pas
bibliques
pour se dire
là on a plus
besoin de diacre
là on a moins
c'est pas une question
des besoins
c'est une question
des dons
des cadeaux
que Dieu fait
à l'église
et en général
il tient sa parole
voilà
d'autres questions
avant qu'on avance
bon
je suis désolé
mais à chaque fois
il y a
ces trucs d'internet
qui apparaissent ici
ok je vais essayer
de continuer
ok on va passer
au troisième point
et là
c'est une considération
plus spécifique
des précurseurs
des diacres
et donc là
l'image
c'est l'image
de l'ordination
des diacres
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
au verset 6
ils les présentèrent
aux apôtres
qu'après avoir prié
leur imposèrent
les mains
donc
c'est ça
qui est un peu
une question
quand on étudie
ces textes
quand les théologiens
étudient ces textes
c'est
d'un côté
les termes
diacres
n'est jamais
mentionné
en tant que substantif
mais les verbes
diacres
il est là
ok
servir en tant que diacre
et en même temps
il y a cette imposition
des mains
qui démontrent
une séparation
une consécration
particulière
pour un office
donc là
on dit
qu'ils sont
des précorseurs
des diacres
mais
quand on arrive
aux lettres
des Paul à Timothée
c'est là
où on aura
l'officialisation
des diacres
dans l'organisation
de l'église
et voilà pourquoi
on dit
qu'ils sont
les précorseurs
des diacres
donc juste
au niveau
des rappels
quelques observations
à l'égard
de cette conviction
que nous devons
remarquer
dans les passages
c'est que
les précorseurs
des diacres
c'est-à-dire
ils sont
je dirais même
les archétypes
quelque part
car on voit
comment
au moins
ceux qui continuent
d'être mentionnés
en acte
ils étaient
non seulement
complètement
prédisposés
à servir aux tables
et travailler
pour l'unité
de l'église
vous vous rappelez
très bien
du contexte
du passage
c'est cette problématique
qui apparaît
entre
la femme
les veuves
des hébreux
et les veuves
héléniques
ok
et donc
les plus probablement
il y a eu
une espèce
de discrimination
des hébreux
envers
les grecs
et
la distribution
n'était pas juste
et donc
les apôtres
ont compris
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
s'arrêter
pour résoudre ça
et qu'ils devraient
consacrer
cette tâche
à une classe
des hommes
remplis de Saint-Esprit
de manière très intentionnelle
ils vont choisir
tous
les sept
avec les noms
grecs
ce qui démontre
l'intentionnalité
par rapport
à
comment nous allons
employer
une personne
à un service
spécifique
aussi
et donc
par là
l'objectif
c'était de régler
l'unité de l'église
ok
donc il y a
ces trois aspects
c'était l'objectif
de libérer
les anciens
et donc
de faire promouvoir
les ministères
de la parole
et de la prière
et donc
à partir de là
on remarque
que
leur priorité
ok
la motivation
je vais revenir
à ces points
à chaque fois
la motivation
principale
pratique
pour les diacres
c'est de voir
la prospérité
du ministère
de la parole
et de la prière
ok
et donc
ce sont ceux
dans la communauté
qui devraient être
reconnus
comme ceux
qui chérissent
les plus
la parole
et la prière
voilà pourquoi
on insiste
sur ces points là
on a même mis
comme critère
d'évaluation
pour les appeler
au diaconat
leur présence
dans leur principale
réunion de l'église
où la parole
est prêchée
et où la communauté
est en train de prier
ok
donc
on ne peut pas
promouvoir
ce qu'on n'apprécie
pas
ce que nous ne sommes
pas en train
d'afficher
et donc
ils sont là
pour résoudre
des problèmes
concrets
tangibles
et ils les font
avec beaucoup
de discrétion
et d'efficacité
donc les problèmes
sont réglés
donc bien sûr
qu'on aura
la sensibilité
par exemple
quand on pense
aux bâtiments
on se demande
parfois
mais après
deux ans
des recherches
comment on n'arrive
pas à trouver
un bâtiment
est-ce qu'on est en train
de manquer
d'efficacité
ce n'est pas le cas
on n'est pas en train
de manquer
d'efforts
ni d'efficacité
c'est tout simplement
on est devant
un défi
qui est historique
dès la réforme
protestante
les églises
sont empêchées
c'est une bataille
spirituelle
peut-être l'indice
ce n'est pas
les manques
d'efficacité
de la part des diacres
c'est les manques
des prières
de la part des anciens
peut-être
donc la réalité
et de toute l'église
c'est que nous
devrions
nous assurer
quand même
que nous sommes
en train de faire
tous nos efforts
pour régler
certains problèmes
donc je suis sûr
et ça c'est aussi
une caractéristique
de la part des diacres
que nous sommes
à l'église
et que nous sommes
en train d'observer
certaines choses
qui sont gênantes
pour nous
donc par exemple
parfois
l'affichage
de la projection
est un peu
tioté
ça se dit en français
penché
et
certains d'entre
les diaconats
vont se dire
j'ai besoin
de régler ça
ça n'affiche pas
l'excellence
qu'on aimerait
communiquer
vous comprenez
et donc
c'est une évidence
quelque part
d'un appel
une évidence
d'un problème concret
qu'on veut régler
peut-être
on va observer
des choses
qui pourraient améliorer
au niveau
de l'accueil
du visuel
des choses
au niveau
je sais pas
des ressources
qu'on pourrait mettre
à disposition
sur internet
ou les sites
de l'église
il y a tellement
des choses
qu'on aimerait
véritablement
développer
de plus en plus
et donc
la question
c'est
je vais chercher
à maximiser
ces services
et moi-même
je vais
faire mon mieux
pour
résoudre
ces problèmes
et à la mesure
où ces personnes
se joignent
à un de ces ministères
ces ministères
ils grandissent
en excellence
en efficacité
donc c'est la capacité
de résoudre
c'est la capacité
d'améliorer
de maximiser
tous les ministères
et nous allons
percevoir
ces choses
selon
en général
c'est un indice
de l'ère
des services
à laquelle je suis appelé
vous comprenez ça ?
donc ils sont là
pour résoudre
des problèmes
avec discrétion
et efficacité
donc c'est une espèce
d'anonymat
ok
ils savent
par exemple
je me rappelle
quand je me suis converti
mon pasteur
il était un excellent
prédicateur
et quand j'étais
appelé au ministère
et que
je me suis joint
à l'équipe
pastorale
j'étais encore
un séminariste
mais j'étais
impressionné
par la qualité
des enseignants
des pasteurs
que cette église avait
elle avait déjà
cinq pasteurs
et moi
j'avais
aucune prétention
sur les moments
de gagner une plateforme
de vouloir apparaître
et donc
j'étais tellement
en train d'apprécier
les ministères
que moi-même
je pensais
à plusieurs opportunités
qu'on pourrait avoir
pour maximiser
la visibilité
de ces prédications
et donc
c'est dans cette direction-là
où on devrait réfléchir
ouvrir des nouvelles frontes
d'évangélisation
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour rendre
les ministères
de la parole
la prière
maximiser
au sein de cette église
je me rappelle
que pour acheter
quand j'étais là
avec paulo junior
à l'époque
il y avait danilo
qui était un pasteur associé
mais qui fonctionnait
comme un diacre
très excellent aussi
et pour acheter
il a dit
tu sais
il m'a dit
derrière
un paulo junior
il y a toujours
un danilo
derrière un poacher
il y a toujours
quelqu'un
qui est là
pour maximiser
les ministères
de la prière
derrière les apôtres
il y avait
les diacres
et donc
c'est dans cette dynamique
qu'on devrait voir
maximiser les ministères
la parole et la prière
en étant réactif
en étant proactif
et en étant
tout simplement passif
dans quel sens
on va revenir à ça
c'est en phase
mais même si mon travail
n'est pas utilisé
j'étais à disposition
ça c'est l'une des choses
les plus importantes
pour les anciens
savoir qu'il y a
des personnes fiables
qui seront toujours là
si jamais un plan B
un plan C
est nécessaire
les anges
se satisfont
de tout simplement
être à disposition
de service du Christ
même si parfois
leur service
ne sera pas utilisé
ils se contentent
de la position
indépendamment
de l'exercice en soi
et en général
quelque chose
qui n'est pas très visible
des questions
avant qu'on passe
à un prochain point
vous êtes pas très interactif
oui
quand on réfléchit
à la distinction
entre
la ligne
des fronts
du ministère
donc Paul va dire ça
Dieu a fait de nous
un spectacle
donc ce sont les anciens
de qui on attend
la visibilité
et ce sont ceux
qui prendront
les risques
de devenir spectacle
dans les sens
des persécutions
etc
donc c'est pas
une notion
de plateforme
de visibilité
qu'on désirerait
c'est tout simplement
l'obligation
d'être dans un poste
où on va
les plus probablement
vivre les privilèges
de voir l'église
croître
et la conversion des âmes
mais nous allons aussi
être les premiers
à souffrir des attaques
donc ça c'est la position
des anciens
par contre
je pense que c'est Spurgeon
qui disait
que
les succès
de son ministère
dépendaient
des prières
anonymes
des veuves
de son église
des femmes
qui n'ont jamais
apparu
et donc
ces services
anonymes
qui peuvent être
très pratiques
pour les sœurs
de l'église
donc par exemple
quand les femmes
sont là
et les hommes aussi
en train de nettoyer
la salle
de ranger
et de préparer
la salle
avant les cultes
ou après les cultes
la plupart
des membres
de l'église
ne sont pas
en train de voir
mais le Seigneur Jésus
il est en train de voir
et donc c'est de se contenter
avec cette description
discrétion
pardon
avec cet anonymat
sachant qu'on est là
pour promouvoir
la visibilité
de Christ
à travers surtout
sa parole
et le ministère
de la prière
des fois
on pourra être
peut-être plus visible
dans nos services
ça dépend vraiment
du service
mais la réalité
c'est que
de toute manière
les contentements
dans le cœur
du diacre
c'est de voir
les ministères prospérer
de voir l'église prospérer
et pas d'avoir
des visibilités
ni un titre
ok
ils savent
que la responsabilité
du titre
est plutôt
une obligation
de vivre
des modèles
de discrétion
et service
ok
David
oui
question
au diacre
il sait
ce que les anciens
veulent
c'est-à-dire
il n'y a pas
de littéralité
pour réaliser
les choses
donc il est très limité
à la volonté
des anciens
où il peut
voir
une demande
un peu comme ça
et s'est organisé
bon
on va revenir
à ce qu'ils font
mais
il y a
ces trois
en phases principales
donc déjà
ils peuvent être
proactifs
à nouveau
dans le sens
où ils sont
en train
de percevoir
des choses
qui pourraient
améliorer
les ministères
de l'église
et donc
ils peuvent
aller proposer
aux anciens
il faut qu'ils travaillent
toujours
en coopération
et en soumission
envers les anciens
en même temps
il faut qu'ils sachent
que même si parfois
il n'est pas en train
de servir
dans son ère
primaire d'entérir
il est là
pour faciliter
les ministères
des anciens
et faciliter
les ministères
des anciens
n'est pas
de faciliter
les préférences
personnelles
des anciens
c'est notamment
lorsque les anciens
sont en train
d'exercer
leur office
envers l'église
mais bien sûr
que
savoir
honorer
les ministères
de la parole
c'est aussi
d'apprendre
avec la Bible
à honorer
les ministères
des anciens
et parfois
juste la gentillesse
envers les anciens
c'est bien
c'est pas un ancien
qui va demander
des choses
triviales
pour ses préférences
personnelles
mais parfois
même une aide
plus particulière
individuelle
peut promouvoir
énormément aussi
son ministère
et donc
ça dépend vraiment
de l'ère des services
de chacun
car certains
peuvent aider
de manière plus proche
de manière plus privée
les anciens
d'autres de manière
plus concrète
envers la projection
de son ministère
dans l'église
et son ministère
et non seulement
les services
envers les anciens
mais c'est aussi
un service
qui aide les anciens
contre les diacres
ils sont en train
de bouger
dans l'articulation
de l'église
pour aider
la communauté
à servir aussi
donc il y a
un nombre
infini
de possibilités
de services
mais c'est
toujours réactif
c'est toujours
proactif
et sous la supervision
des anciens
aussi
ça répond à ta question
donc
une fois par exemple
que les anciens
ont reconnu
un diacre
comme officiel
et peut-être
qu'il sera
les diacres
consacrés
à une tâche spécifique
bien sûr
que dans ces domaines
il y aura
beaucoup de libertés
pour faire les choses
mais c'est important
d'avoir aussi
cette interaction
constante
avec les anciens
oui
c'est ça
en fait
ce sont les deux choses
moi je suis
l'esclave
les serviteurs
officiels
de l'église
c'est à dire
peu importe
quels soient
les besoins
qui est là
donc par exemple
je donne à chaque fois
l'exemple des disney
où tous les employés
peu importe
quelle soit leur position
ils ont l'engagement
et la responsabilité
si jamais ils croisent
des bassures
des déchets par terre
il doit attraper
sinon il risque
de perdre son emploi
même si c'est les CEO
il doit le faire
et donc
s'il y a un besoin
pour l'église
et on a besoin
que certains se consacrent
ils vont toujours dire
mais voici
ok
mais en même temps
ils peuvent aussi servir
dans une ère particulière
pour laquelle il est plus doué
et pour laquelle
il a plus intérêt
c'est clair la réponse ?
c'est à dire que
en fait
imaginant
une personne
devient diacre
qui travaille
sur mon génère
et c'est du tout
mais que
en plus des années
c'est à dire
en fait
qu'il n'a plus besoin
de le faire
de sa tendance
en étant diable
c'est que
en fait
il doit travailler
il doit encore servir
pour une autre
oui
la vocation
est plus importante
que l'ère du service
lui-même
car ce qui va définir
sa vocation
c'est une nouvelle
presque une nouvelle identité
donnée par Dieu
c'est une vocation
les vocations bibliques
comme elles passent
par la
la capacitation
elles n'ont pas
en fait
en termes
en termes des mandats
dans la structure
d'une église
il y a plusieurs églises
qui vont travailler
en termes des mandats
mais même les mandats
ne doit pas déterminer
la conviction
d'un appel
pour toujours
c'est une vocation
à moins que
je suis là
en train de travailler
en tant qu'ancien
mais je perçois
car il y a
même si ce n'est pas
une étape
envers l'ancienat
il y a
beaucoup
d'éléments
qui s'achévauchent
et nous n'avons pas
la capacité
inspirée
de reconnaître
les appels
et donc
personnellement
je peux avoir tort
par rapport
à ma conviction
mais aujourd'hui
ma conviction
c'est d'être appelé
et l'église
peut avoir tort
dans son jugement
mais
à nouveau
les plus tôt
on voit des signes
des disqualifications
on doit savoir
reconnaître
que ce n'est pas
notre appel
par contre
si on est
véritablement appelé
et convaincu
c'est un appel
pour toujours
ok
donc il n'y a pas
des retraites
en termes
des convictions
d'appel
donc même
si je n'ai pas
les titres
je continuerai
de servir
et d'agir
en tant qu'un
diacre
là où je serai
oui
tiens
sclave par office
c'est ça
oui
toujours
voilà l'ordre
des priorités
aussi dans l'organisation
des points
tout ce qui
tout ce qui s'occupera
à faire
l'une des questions
qui doit se poser
c'est de quelle manière
ces services
c'est en train
de libérer
les anciens
pour la prière
et pour la parole
aider
à articuler
l'église
pour qu'ils puissent
servir
mieux servir
donc ça peut
ne pas être
une aide
directe
aux anciens
mais par exemple
si notre église
commence à structurer
un groupe de maisons
un diacre
qui s'y met
bénévole
pour par exemple
faire la cartographie
des membres
voir qui habite
dans quelle place
et aider
à organiser ces choses
il est en train
de prêter un service
pour l'avancement
des ministères
de l'église
envers la parole
et la prière
et l'unité
de l'église
donc c'est toujours
cette question
de quelle manière
mon service
est en train
de promouvoir
ces choses
ça c'est une décision
qu'on doit prendre
encore
avec les anciens
moi je pense
que l'utilité
des mandats
c'est pour
qu'on puisse
faire les points
pour qu'on puisse
être responsable
dans une évaluation
constante
pour renouveler
une affirmation
mais pas forcément
pour
pour suspendre
on appelle
et il faut
qu'on sache aussi
qu'il y a toujours
une marge
de croissance
dans tous les aspects
dans la conscience
de ce qui a tendu
de moi
en tant qu'ancien
dans la conscience
et la conviction
de mon appel
et dans la manière
dont tu exerces
mon ministère
il y a toujours
une marge
des perfectionnements
des progressions
qui est importante
donc il faut
qu'on soit
suffisamment
convaincu
de ces choses
aujourd'hui
même si pas
parfaitement
car on ne sera
jamais parfait
dans l'exercice
de ces choses
oui encore
des questions
non c'est juste
une période
soit deux ans
quatre ans
ou par exemple
nous allons
oui oui
par exemple
on est
on vous a ordonné
en tant que diacre
d'accord
d'ici deux ans
on doit
voilà
représenter à l'église
vos noms
la nomination
pour les renouvellements
de votre ministère
ok
donc c'est
soit on continue
soit on s'arrête